good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome to baby district
council's planning committee meeting
of the wednesday the 18th of november
may i first of all remind you of some of
the domestic arrangements
please ensure that microphones and
cameras
are turned off when not in use that you
do not interrupt other speakers
that if you wish to speak point of order
declare and or interest or request an
adjournment
please use the hands function on the
taskbar
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative communication lines
open ie other scope chats
and that if you are connect contacted by
a third party during the application you
should bring this to the legal advisor's
attention
if you are attending the meet and to
speak and persistently
interrupt the meeting you may be asked
to leave
if members do lose connection to the
meeting
they must contact the member support
officer
mandy smith as soon as possible
i'd like to remind everyone present that
this meeting will be broadcast live to
the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting you have
consented to be unrecorded
sorry by entering this meeting as a
speaker you're also
consenting to being recorded by the
council
and to the possible use of the same
recordings for webcast and or training
purposes
the council members of the public and
press may
record film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
right i'd now like to introduce the
officers present
mark russell area planner manager
jasmine waynard
the case officer ian d press
the plan and lawyer excuse me robert
carmichael
the governance officer and thomas penner
the heritage officer here today
right i'll now move to the agenda
members
and item number one is substitutes
and apologies uh i'll ask the rob
uh to do a roll call of members present
please
thank you chair we have no substitu
substitute or apologies
um so i'll just run through everyone's
name so
councillor suez good morning present
councilman melanie barrett present
that's the peter beer
present counselor david busby here
that's the lee jameson present counselor
mary mclaren
president councillor adrian osborne good
morning all present
that's allison owen good morning present
that's a lee parker present
councillor stephen plum president john
johnson
i don't think you called out oh
apologies counselor hinton
i'm feeling left out there i i don't
know you are on my list
i must have just got lost my apologies
counselor hinton
i hadn't lost to kensala hinton
right thank you we're all present right
we'll move to item number two is
declarations of interest
are there any to do declared
no
yes parker's hand up sorry oh sorry
uh yes he's off my screen um i
have to scroll down a bigger pardon
kenzler
i can't see you but robert's highlighted
you to me uh yes cancer parker
yep thank you chad no problems at all um
i'm not sure if it's declaration of
interest or not i'll take some advice
but obviously i'm ward member
um for the application here
and as such i wish to speak as ward
member
and abstain from voting um come the vote
right so that means you will only take
part
uh when i asked the ward member to um
if they wish to speak and if you do you
will have up to five minutes in which to
address the committee
and questions would be put to you and
after that
you would then take no further part in
the proceedings
is that correct yep that's correct yeah
and i'll get the legal
advisor to confirm all that um yes
indeed chairman i i
can i be heard yes i have got mine yes
i'm on music
um yes i just for the benefit of anyone
watching this or anyone in the committee
not who's not a regular tender
um this council baba does not have
some councils including our neighbor
mid-suffolk have a rule in their own
constitution
there's goes beyond the letter of the
law that says a councillor on the
committee who happens to be the ward
member must not
vote and sits out if we were in the
council chamber would sit opposite
out of their normal chair on the other
side of the room and speak but not vote
we at baber do not have that rule but
it's it's
for the individual ward members
discretion and choice as to whether they
feel it's appropriate to carry on as a
member of
the committee a voting member of the
committee or to
do what council parker's doing this
morning which is entirely proper and
he's made that choice so i've noted that
i'm quite happy with that chairman
thank you very much kenzler parker has
exercised his right to do that
um right i'll come to you and do course
counselor parker
then we'll move on to item number three
which is to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 7th of
october are there any points of accuracy
you've got them in front of you
no they're all okay then i need somebody
to propose
and second them please i'll propose that
mr chairman
thank you councillor osborne seconded by
councillor ayers do you wish to speak
and slayers
no right uh i'll ask rob to do a roll
call of um
the minutes of the 7th of october
thank you chair so if members could
please respond with
for against or abstain
john hinton oh
[Music]
caster stephen plum poor they chair
that is unanimously carried thank you
very much
then they are approved and they'll be
signed at the next practical opportunity
that i have to sign them right we'll
move on to item number four
um oh sorry yes which is to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the
fourth of november these were
circulated yesterday members um
so hopefully you've had time to have a
look um is there anything that you wish
to
um of accuracy that you wish to
find out from it
nope you're all happy then i need to
propose under secondary please
counselor airs you're proposed and
counselor owen you're saying do you wish
to speak
no and no one else no other hands gone
up that i can see
right then i'll ask for a roll call uh
to approve the minutes of the fourth of
november
uh rob thank you chair so if again if
members could please respond with four
against or abstain
council sue reyes four
casa melanie barrett four has a pita
beer
four council david busby
four that's a john hinton
counselor hinton when the buttons work
for
councillor castle jameson for
cousin mary mclaren four casa adrian
osborne four
councillor allison owen oh that's the
lee parker
for cancer stephen plum
thank you chair again that is
unanimously carried thank you very much
and again members these have been signed
at the next practical opportunity
thank you we'll move on to item number
five which is to read
receive any notifications of petitions
um robert have you anything to report
then receive chair thank you very much
we'll move on to item number six which
is a standard
in on our agenda site inspections
officers
are there any site inspections i have to
ask you
mark yeah it's the usual chair we're
still not doing them
thank you very much and members
none thank you very much right we don't
have any
so we can now move on to item number
seven
we should plan an application for
determination it's on page 13
and i'll ask jasmine weimar to the case
officer
to introduce this application to the
committee
over to you thank you chair and good
morning members
um i'll just get up my screen so you can
see it
yep good
can i just check you can see my screen
and mouse yes
uh yes i can see both so i'm assuming
everybody else can
um so as a general reminder this
presentation should be seen as an
accompaniment to the main committee
report and should not be understood in
any sort of isolation
thank you the application is for the
erection of a nursery school
for children aged one to five years with
associated infrastructure
the site is located in a grade two
agricultural field
just south off of the a134 which leads
both to colchester and
sudbury and berries and edmonds the site
is outside of the settlement boundary
which sort of starts around the street
just here
the um as you can see the surroundings
are predominantly
open agricultural fields and the built
form of assington
is again still rural in character and
linear in its form concentrated along
the street
there's a public right of way that
starts just along here and a permissive
footpath that would connect the site
to this public right of way as well
the site extends 0.7 hectares and again
this just shows you the sort of
immediate surroundings
just here
so in terms of constraints you've got
the grade one listed
edmonds church to the west and again
you've also got a grade two listed coach
house a little bit further west just out
of shot
you've then got the grade two listed the
glebe house to the east
and south you again out of shot is the
greater listed hill farmhouse
there are a row of tpo's along the
western edge
and north northern edge of the site
the site does fall within the argo fen
triple si
risk impact zone which extends for three
kilometers
um there isn't there is archaeological
potential on site
and the store valley sla starts opposite
the site and wraps sort of around it
so this way um
then we've got some site photos so i've
sort of done a 360 view around the site
as you can see it's very isolated open
and rural in character there's other
than you know the historic building of
the church
and in the far distance here is the
street there's there's no sort of built
form
and again that just shows you the the
church slightly clearer
and you've then got the access into the
site over here
and um the opposite the access
you can then sort of view where the a134
starts
um which is just sort of around this
bend over there
so these have been identified as the key
issues within the decision-making
process
and things for members to consider so
it's outside of the settlement boundary
it's within the setting in significance
a list of buildings within the argo
fence site of special scientific
interest
risk impact zone next to the stir
valley special landscape area there are
several trees on site with tree
preservation orders on
and it's a provision of a child care
facility
so the existing site plan again just
sort of reiterates what's been shown in
the
um aerial maps agricultural land
and the trees that are falling within
the site as well
the elevations show that the building
would be single story
with um an overall barn style building
um whilst no specific manufacturers
details of the materials have been given
at this stage
um the images just give members an idea
of the overall look
of the building as they've sort of
specified general materials that are
going to be used
the floor plans show that there is cycle
storage
provided alongside some other store
areas
a covered outside play area um admins or
staff
room offices um and three rooms
for the children's use of sperm
you've then got the site layout um so
the car parking provides 18 spaces
for parents or dropping off whatever it
might be
and 16 spaces for staff the access
is taken opposite the entrance to
ashington hall just off of the a134
um from an existing agricultural access
as you saw on my site photos
just here there'd be a sliding gate
access
and gate across the access
um the outside space is predominantly
grass with flower meadow margins and
hedgerow
they'd be planting further trees and
retaining the existing
and there'd be a grass margin separating
the site from the main agricultural
field
so more specifically um the images give
you an idea of the landscaping details
again
no specific manufacturer's details have
been given but the sort of general
approach has been given so there would
be a
1.5 meter gaming wall to the frontage of
the site around the car park
there'd be a 1.2 meter high timber post
and rail fence
around the remainder of the site there'd
be bod paved with rough shingle to the
parking areas
uh black asphalt to the access a five
bar agricultural sliding gate to the
entrance
um and then concrete tiling to the rear
patio area
and as i've sort of mentioned the body
pave um would be again
the other form of hard standing to the
frontage um
in terms of soft landscaping um the
species
sort of given just to the bottom here
are all considered primarily native um
which are considered
acceptable which obviously would be all
of the the remainder of the site
in terms of the landscape impact um
place services landscaping objected to
the proposal based on the listed points
just here
as the photos show just again
reiterating the site is open
um land with views extending miles
across the surrounding landscape
it's in a very prominent location at the
entrance to assington just off of the
a134
it would be the only modern building
that is not connected to agricultural
use within the immediate locality
because we've got sort of the
um built form along the street and then
the historic church
and the gleep house sort of to one of
the other sides
listed buildings all within the
settlement boundary um
it's again it's in a higher level in
comparison to the remainder of the field
you can see it
slightly falls and it would stand out
significantly in the wider views of the
area
which further supports the arguments
around the setting of heritage assets
which i'll come on to
so um the ashington neighborhood plan um
currently has a limited way but these
two policies that i've listed here are
the most relevant
um to identifying how important the
landscape is within the locality
and policy 12 identifies the site as
being in a landscape sensitive area
um policy 13 identifies views which
should be protected
so the specific one um relating to the
site is view
for which again extends across this
field
just over here the
views and landscape are key themes that
run throughout the plan
including being referenced in other
policies such as policy 17 and 19
which relate to heritage assets and
design considerations
the plan currently has limited weight as
i've said however its direction
strongly supports the findings of both
place services landscaping and the
heritage team
who both conclude the proposed
development would be located in a highly
sensitive area
disrupting the overall undeveloped
countryside location which is intrinsic
to the setting of three nearby listed
buildings
and the overall character of assington
so natural england and place services
ecology have identified that if foul
water is to be discharged other
other than to a main sewer there could
be the potential to detrimentally affect
the
nearby tree less eye which is arghafen
just here
um it doesn't have to be right next door
to the triple si as i saw mentioned
earlier to have an impact
um naturally england have an impact
risk zone which extends three kilometers
or in all directions
around the triple s i um details were
submitted late and are on the
table papers um we can't confirm at this
stage whether they are acceptable
details as it will require
further consultation with natural
england and ecology
but they are going to be reassessed
um so there are four tpos on the western
edge of the site
which i've shown in some site photos
here
um which are the ones of concern there
are also two to the north of the site
but
are less of concern so the council's
arbor cultural officer
raised significant concerns that the
nursery school use
involving children aged one to five
could conflict with mature trees on site
the trees have large canopies as you can
see and their
age means they are more likely to have
dead wood which would fall on site
um there's been insufficient
consideration and justification which
would demonstrate that these trees have
been duly considered
in the design of the scheme and what
this actually means in practical terms
it's been proposed that they could fence
around the trees but this was not
considered adequate
and pruning of the trees at any point
throughout the lifetime of the
development
would not be considered acceptable
either based on
the fact it could undermine the value
and health of these trees
most of the trees and the localities you
might have seen on the
constraints map and around this entrance
into assington
are protected by tree preservation
orders
which again further reiterates their
value to the wider landscape
the photos show the extent of the
canopies and i'm not sure if you can
sort of see
but when i've been out on site there's
actually some wood that's already fallen
in branches and they sort of scatter
beyond this canopy canopy further over
so just to show you the exact locations
of the nearby listed buildings
and you've got the grade one listed
church of st
edmund you've got the grade 2 listed
coach house greatly listed hill
farmhouse and grade 2 listed the glebe
house
um the site sits very centrally
within these listed buildings and their
sort of setting
as well in terms of the heritage harm
and the council's heritage team has
identified three harm at three different
levels in regards to three different
impacts
so you've got a low to medium level of
less than substantial harm
to the undeveloped setting and important
view and the historic relationship with
the glebe house of
the church of saint edmund a low level
of lessened substantial harm
to the glebe house's historic
relationship with the church
and a very low level of less and
substantial harm to the undeveloped
agricultural setting of hill farmhouse
so in terms of the significance of list
of buildings
this includes their setting this is not
a separate consideration it's an
inherent part of the assessment as per
paragraph 190 of the mppf
as you can see the gleep house falls
under former vicarage land
over here which has strong historic
associations with the church
including this sort of open intervening
land between them which
is integral to their setting um
although there's been some sort of
discussion around the a134
running between these two buildings
there's actually
obviously evidence that there's been a
track running through here
for many many years anyway so
the the very built form here is going to
be the significant change
so again i just wanted to show you some
more site photos
um as i've touched on the a134
is is not really visually intrusive in
terms of
the visibility of the church and the
sort of overall
undeveloped surroundings um
any sort of development here would block
the view to the church
and again it blocks that significant
open
gap the tree coverage and how visible
the buildings
are is not actually a consideration to
the historic setting as per historic
england's guidance
however just to reiterate that
regardless of tree coverage
the site is clearly visible within the
setting of the grade one listed church
and so i've provided two photos from the
same location during different times of
the year just so you can see the
different levels
of coverage and the fact that the church
regardless of
um whether you know we consider
um visibility of them as part of their
setting it isn't but
just so you can sort of appreciate that
it is going to still be visible
regardless
so in terms of heritage scales
no harm is an opportunity that you could
approve it with no
balance needed um
then on the sliding scale um the harm
that has been identified under this
proposal is somewhere between the yellow
and
the orange which is
refused unless public benefits outweigh
the heritage harm
red then basically means things along
the lines of demolition
of listed buildings so obviously that
that's not why
that's why it's not substantial harm in
this case
however all less than substantial harm
requires public benefit balancing
regardless of the level that has been
identified of that lesson substantial
harm
more generally the phrase less than
substantial does not mean it's not
important and can be dismissed it's
still highly important
and requires significant balancing with
public benefits
less than substantial just means it's a
different type of impact
too substantial as i said earlier
the only level where a proposal does not
need
significant balancing is no harm
everything beyond that
any degree of harm has to be
significantly balanced
paragraph 193 of the mppf is a good
point to start with
more important the asset greater weight
should be given
and to ensuring no harm is caused two of
the identified harms relate to a grade
one listed church which is the highest
listing possible and therefore great
weight is attached to preserving its
significance and setting
therefore i'd reiterate again that
public benefits have to be significant
truly for the wider public benefit and
heavily justified
so in terms of the public benefits
paragraph 196
enables the public benefit balance it
has to be read in combination with the
other paragraphs of section 16 of the
mppf which
we've touched on a couple of those
previously this includes
the importance of setting writing based
on the listing category
and justifying harm identified here are
the possible public benefits of the
scheme
these are then weighed against the
reasons that officers believe justified
refusal
so four is the retention
of 14 existing jobs which are already
within the district
there is the potential but no guarantee
for four additional jobs and two
apprenticeships
and the provision of a child care
facility against this
it's not considered um a school under
the mppf
and they're there and therefore the mppf
does not automatically support it as a
public benefit as it would do with the
school
it's a private child care facility and
it's not accessible for all
therefore it's not a wider public
benefit
not just heritage issues to be
considered there are other impacts that
weigh against the proposal
there are other locations that could
accommodate
the development within the locality
without such harm
there's no reasonable justification why
this
has to be located on this site
specifically
um so the most important policies to the
proposal
are considered to be up-to-date and
therefore we do not engage the tilted
balance in favor of sustainable
development
however just to reiterate the general
direction
that the presumption in favor of
sustainable development takes i've
included this paragraph from the mppf
the presumption therefore does not apply
automatically
where protected assets including triple
s eyes and listed buildings are affected
in any way
so in conclusion there's been no
sufficient justification for the nursery
to be in this location specifically
therefore there's no justification for
the harm that's being caused
the argument that it has been difficult
to locate other suitable sites
and that they are being evicted from
their current premises again
does not address why the nursery has to
be located on this site specifically
furthermore the parish council have
indicated they would be willing to
assist
in this matter to help the nurse who
find a premises or
suitable site notably
the nursery wasn't based in assington
originally and there are a range
of surrounding villages as well that
could be more suitable
the recommendation presented to members
is therefore
one of refusal based on the listed
reasons here
thank you for listening thank you thank
you
uh right echo i think it's
because you've got the screen up can you
take that down
yep bear with me just stop presenting
thank you members may want to come to
that in a moment
um uh right um
members is there any um points that
you'd like clarified by the case officer
i've got one
just to kick off um you referred
two or three times to three kilometers
i think this was to argo fan or the blue
bell waters i knew it growing up
um and 1.6
miles is three kilometers 1.6 miles
uh three kilometers is slightly more
than 1.6 miles so it's within that risk
impact zone basically
right uh it's just that you gave what
i can in my mind work out 1.6 miles
i can't three kilometers um so uh
i think it's important so it's about one
point eight then they usually
miles you would say um
bear with me because i can probably just
lovely if you could that would be
helpful
chair the uh sorry the the three
kilometers is a three kilometer
consultation zone so anything three
kilometers out from
our defend would be consulted on that's
that's why there was a reference to
three kilometers
right thank you uh i just want to know
what three kilometers was
in mars charities 1.8
miles they're about that's what i
thought thank you
thank you very much uh members is an any
any oh yes uh councillor barrett
somebody else thank you um you meant
jasmine warning you mentioned in your um
summary of the um factors against
that there was limited public access
to their nursery provision because it's
a private
nursery but families are eligible for
free childcare uh i think i think that's
available to to everyone so surely that
is accessible for all
can you clarify that uh thank you
councillor barrett
um in terms of we we do acknowledge that
you know
families are entitled um to free
childcare but the
i suppose it's really to reiterate that
it it's not
the same as being a school there isn't
like a specific
catchment area um or you know any
um i suppose with
you know suffolk county council with
their education obviously they have to
find everyone
a suitable school to to attend and that
usually has sort of a catchment area
whereas with the private nursery
facility it's sort of
um i suppose a case of parents have to
put themselves on waiting lists and bits
and pieces like that
and that's sort of where we were where
that presentation point was going
um hopefully that clarifies but i'll let
you answer
uh i'm not sure that's a clear
answer uh we have the county council who
will be speaking later he may be able to
clarify but
that is your interpretation of what i
would afford
um i think is what um councillor barrett
was uh
asked and um it's it's not a clear
enough answer i don't think i don't know
councillor barrett does that help you at
all
i think i think there is a case for
saying there is public benefit
because any pair any parent can can send
their child there
regardless of income yeah well i think
members you've
you've heard the comment from the
officer and you must give that whatever
weight you feel in due course
um mr before i've got i've got
um uh councillor mclaren but um
mark russell did you want to come in you
were waving i i was
sorry yeah i was i was fiddling about
and yeah i just want to speak actually
uh chair
uh just to say that um yeah accepted
about the answer there um i
think the uh yeah where we're coming
from is yes you can make the
argument that is of a benefit of the
type but jasmine was just trying to
describe the difference between that and
a state school let's say but
one can make the argument there is a
benefit of some sort yeah yeah
i i i agree there with you on that
comment
uh councillor mclaren
i'm sorry councillor barrett have you
finished
sorry
no it wasn't you it was me thank you
chair
jasmine um nowhere on the paper could
i'm trying to assess the traffic impact
i couldn't find how many nursery places
uh would be filled on any one day
is that is that number available
no 16 parking paid spaces for visitors
but i can't see how many nursery places
um i don't believe that's something i
have put in the report um
and it's not something that i have at
hand
and it might be something to ask the
nursery owner who i believe is going to
be speaking
the second question jasmine uh where
there was a public comment that there
was no shortage
of nursery play nursery school places
i was just wondering how that is
calculated
on an area basis i that's something i
don't really know a lot about
um again that's not really something i'm
too familiar with um i am aware that
i think when the well the nursery as it
currently is in its
location at the minute i believe that
there's a waiting list for that specific
nursery but i don't think
again it's not the same as a school
in you know there's a catchment area as
such um
so i'm not sure how that is calculated i
don't know if mark oh
i'll just come in there bear if i may uh
we do have the county councillor
uh and we do have the um applicant
who's going to speak i think that's a
good question you've put
i'd put it to both of them in due course
thank you very much jasmine thank you
chair
thank you is there any other um
questions
um clarification
yes can uh cancel airs yes
yes um i i quite find it quite
disappointing
as a retired teacher and having taught
nursery
that the mppf said it's not educational
well statistics prove that from the
years of three to seven
they are the most receptive and that's
where children
learn the most so that that bit does
worry me
thank you can you comment on that
jasmine
yeah certainly and i you know i think
everyone would agree that
children in early years really really
benefit from early education i don't
think anyone's disputing that
i think it's it's just really within the
mppf
it defines a school and you can't
say based on you know how they run and
the difference between them
that they are they are separate you've
got schools
and child care facilities um whilst i
completely
appreciate the sort of level of teaching
and development that happens they are
different
thank you is there a is there a
paragraph referred to that in the
uh national planning policy framework
i believe it's paragraph 94 but i can
check that for you
right i've got it in front of me so i'll
check it's just that so i can
follow it and make sure uh
important shows at school yes but page
27
if you've got the um framework in front
of you
and it's paragraph 94. thanks very much
that's fine
uh right we've got um uh
who was it i think it was uh canceler
busby or what's that yeah
i was just going to ask a question you
referred to the tpos and that pruning
the trees would potentially damage them
but
i mean from my recollection we we prune
tpo trees
all the time and i guess if the the
trees that were close to the view
started to block the view out we'd be
quite happy to prune them
to retain the view wouldn't we
um so in terms of the pruning specific
the
specifically sort of the technical
details of it this is advice i've taken
from the council's agricultural officer
who specifically just deals with
trees and tpo's across the district um
so i can't really comment on the pruning
aspect
um in terms of the view as i sort of
touched on in my presentation
the view and the historic setting
um is not affected by
tree coverage it's sort of irrespective
of that because you can experience
setting of a listed building in several
different ways
um so whilst i appreciate where you're
coming from
i don't think that the sort of view
being
um opened up by the loss of tpos
is something that we would want to
encourage basically
but don't we just following on from uh
councillor busby
don't we uh where there are tpos
if we feel they're a threat for any
reason either a branch is going to fall
and we can see it or that we do need to
fin it
because it's shade and properties or
what have you um
i thought we had the facility to do
minor
repairs improvements safety aspects
is that not correct
mark did you want to answer that what
what you say is correct chair i think
the uh
horoculturalist issue here is that this
will lead to further pressure to
to to lop or fail the trees if they're
producing danger for the children that
that was the aspect
we're coming from that's an
interpretation from mr pizza
yeah thank you all right any other um
uh points of clarification before we
move on
no all right thank you very much
um right we'll now go to the public
speakers
i have the parish council representative
mr andrew hill
you sir have three minutes in which to
address the committee
and rob will you do the timing um so if
you'd like to turn your camera on
mr hill and your mic on
oh i'm upside down i think oh yes so you
are
i don't know how you get out of that one
we just do this here we go
easiest way exactly
and i can hear you so when you're ready
thank you
thank you good morning 32 residents have
formally objected to this application
the parish council feels that the
officer's report is fair and balanced
and therefore i'm here to highlight our
three key concerns
first of all there's a conflict with the
neighborhood plan there's a harm caused
by a very poor choice of sight
and third there's a lack of a credible
economic and educational case
on the neighborhood plan we spent a lot
of time and
the community spent a lot of effort
putting this together it would be very
much a real kick in the teeth for the
community if the recommendation
of the planet's officer for refusal was
overturned by this committee
secondly the choice of sites is is a
poor one
the application site is an open
countryside visible from a number of
public footpaths and enjoyed by
thousands of people
as they travel on the 134 the officer
makes clear
it's in an elevated position so it
impacts across the village
over a wide area the heritage team makes
very clear that the application will
cause permanent
irrevocable harm to the setting of the
15th century sir edmonds
church i also would like to go back to
the agricultural officer's point
that it is an unsafe site for parents
and children only recently we had
high winds and the whole site was
scattered with large branches
so in all likelihood those trees would
have to be filled
of the consulting consulted that means
that suffolk highways
place services the heritage team suffolk
preservation society
natural england and the tree officer all
have concerns and objections to this
site
the main voice in favor is the economic
development team
and the educational side of things and
i'll speak on that topic now
this is clearly a superb business with
an outstanding offstage rating
and it's a valuable asset to the
education of our children and the
ability of parents to work
i think it is accessible to lots of
people it surprised us to read that the
economic development team has been
unable to find a suitable location
for this business so we made our own
inquiries
team has conducted when approached by
this business seeking to relocate
it turns out the economic development
team only searches for the businesses
specific requirement
in this case the search was for a dream
location an open rural countryside site
but near a main road clearly that's a
difficult thing to find
and they weren't able to at this
particular moment in time
however given the pressure the business
is under to move quickly
it is surely reasonable to ask them to
widen the search criteria to look beyond
just the dream's location even if it's
only on a temporary basis maybe for a
few years
if you do this you quickly find as you
might expect in a recession
there are a number of suitable
properties in hadley and subway in
particular
this is one of them i found on rightmove
right now you can see it's
available for vent it's approximately
the same size
as the building which is proposed in
this application
and clearly that's available now it's
brand new and it's ready to go
but there's also sites which are in the
sort of rural dream location
and maybe these sites weren't available
when the economic team was initially
consulted
but here's one for example enlisted that
is time chair that's that side
welfare thank you thank you very much uh
mr hill
uh i'll service any questions for you um
i've just got one the first picture that
you held up
where was that i heard you say the other
one was along melfort but where was the
first one
um the first one is in hadley thank you
that's that's valiant
okay it's more sustainable for transport
there's a local population where people
can walk to the site
thank you you've answered my question um
members
any questions uh for clarification
to mr hill
um councillor ayers followed by
councillor busby
yes um thank you and chair um i just
wonder i think was it either 32 or 34
mr hill of people that objected but i
believe the population is
402 of washington so um
i just wondered about those figures
thank you
the population of 402 includes children
of course
so therefore um 32 people represent
something like 15 i would say of the
adult population
and bear in mind that you have to put
your home address
publicly on the internet in order to
make an objection
to do so is a substantial undertaking
for people and there's a lot of people
who are very reluctant to do it
so that number is extremely high
thank you councillor busby
yeah any of these uh sites that you
are going to suggest that they have
instead of this one are any of them in
asington
uh i i wish uh i desperately wish that
we were able to find one in actington
because clearly that would uh negate the
sort of nimby approach that we just won
it out of our backyard
it's absolutely not the case that there
may well be a site in ashington
coming available in the near future but
at the moment
there isn't however there's one in
hadley there's one
any other questions
yes sorry who's that
it's it's adrian okay okay so i was born
yep sorry
yeah i see your hand now somewhere else
yeah i'd just like to um
continue with the comment that uh
counselor busby made
and um i very much um
uh like like the attitude that you had
about
um uh about finding another p
you've always said that you would you
would be able to find somewhere else
uh for them if if they came to you you
have a a local plan coming
around surely within your local plan you
should be able to actually
um get that to to a position where
uh that land would be available it does
sound to me like you are being nimby i'm
afraid
uh can you can you highlight one in your
uh local neighborhood plan or have you
done so i think is the question
it's it's it's it's not a short answer
to that question i mean clearly
um the local the local neighborhood plan
makes the ability for business nursery
to come into our parish unfortunately
this nursery did not approach the parish
council and did not
look at the neighborhood plan if they
had done so we would happily have worked
with them to find a site
now so i think the question i'm sorry
because it is questions
to you for clarification did did the
is there a site highlighted in the
neighborhood plan is what i think
councillor osborne
has asked them for us for a nursery
school
yeah part of the process of neighborhood
plan
is to identify the needs of the village
and the nursery school was not
identified at that stage
and we had no knowledge that this
nursery school needed a home
had we had that knowledge when we did
the neighborhood plan we
you know absolutely would have um found
a site for it thank you thank you
well i would say mr chairman that that's
18 months
18 months i was born
it is a question to the um
parish council speaker at this moment
you can bring that up in your debate if
you wish
the lead for this site is not 18 sorry i
don't think you can answer that anymore
i think you've made
you've given us the answer to his
question that it wasn't possible
um officer mark
russell thank you sir i just wanted to
re-emphasize the fact as as jasmine said
in her presentation that the
i suppose if we're having this
discussion in a year or so time it would
have more meaning but at the moment the
neighborhood plan while showing a
direction of travel
does still carry limited weight so
whichever way you want to approach that
discussion it has still got limited
weight sure
correct yep that is correct thank you
councillor hinton your question
come on yes
thank you mr chairman um
question for mr hill uh i believe that
the existing
site for the nursery is in little corner
what's the distance from little corner
to
the present the proposed site
uh by road i would guess
it is something like five miles
something like that four miles
um that's mainly because it's a rural
route and it's quite twisty turny to get
from there to this side
alternatively go back into something and
then out again it'll be a similar
distance
right i know it's near the television
area the old bbc television area up
there
i wasn't aware that was five miles but
i've no idea so i have to accept not not
as the crow flies
but by vote yeah i it's certainly a
bendy road you're quote right there
any other questions no
thank you very much then mr hill we'll
carry on
thank you thank you um we don't have an
objector
um but we do have a supporter mr matthew
late
um who have three minutes in which to
address the committee
perhaps you'd like to turn your camera
on and your mic on to start with
i'll see if i can hear you i can hear
you i can't see you yet
right uh i do have my camera on
yeah yeah ah there you are mr matthew
late yep
wait when you're ready sir uh you have
three minutes and rob will tell you that
okay to address the committee thank you
thank you for letting me speak today
i'm matthew lee a local business owner
and father of
a lovely three and a half year old
autistic girl with special needs
who attends your barn nursery and has
done since you with one
a little bit of backstory to understand
my point's a bit better
we were aware our daughter was autistic
when we started looking at nursery
reporter
and wanted naturally to find the best
environment for her
that would cater for her specific needs
we looked at many
surprisingly at the time yorli was the
only nursery we found that had an ethos
that hit our requirements forest schools
environmental play areas and as much
outdoor learning as possible
seem perfect for my daughter's sometimes
obsessive fascination with
all things nature so
as some of you may know raising a young
child with special needs
can sometimes be an emotional sometimes
scary
sometimes worrying thing to do you worry
about
everything the milestones she's failing
to meet
and what the future may or may not have
in store for her we needed
help we joined and are still members of
many council-funded
and charitable support groups that would
help arya achieve a maximum potential
but never knew that yuliban would
quickly become our primary point of
support in
all areas they took arya under their
wing
trained their staff to where they needed
to be and like all children that attend
took time to understand her as an
individual and build
strong relationships that have in turn
produced huge improvements
to her early development and social
skills that have far
exceeded ours and her pediatrician's
expectations
like all children arya suffered
massively lockdown
with the change in her routine and the
now near non-existent
social interaction with her peers arya
had regressed in a big way
she would become extremely distressed
with being in close proximity to other
young children
among many other issues working closely
with yorli
we've been able to get my daughter back
to far exceeding my expectations again
this is solely down to the hard work
patience
and professional dedication that the
staff put into their work every day
i believe yoriban is one of a kind
i believe that arya's short story is a
success story for children with special
needs
and for all children preparing to start
their school life
yoriban provides vital support for local
families
and to give them the opportunity to
offer their services to more young
children living in the
area is extremely important and makes a
real difference in people's lives
they should be given all the help
possible to achieve that
and on behalf of all the parents and all
the children at yorley barn i
implore you to make the right decision
and to support the planning
to please give them that opportunity or
any positive impact it's going to have
will far
outweigh any negative
thank you sir for that um
comments uh members is there any points
of clarification
that you'd like to ask the supporter
any hands up no
thank thank you very much for that thank
you we'll move on
um right we'd um still don't have an
objective so i will now ask the
applicant donna page to speak you also
have three minutes in which to address
the committee
perhaps uh mr lee you turn your
camera off thank you
donna page hello hello i can't see you
yet
it's my camera's on uh right
i don't know why you haven't appeared on
our screen rob can you help
uh chair it might just be it just might
take a
couple of moments because when a person
starts speaking it takes a couple of
minutes for them to come onto the main
screen
do some talking so that the camera turns
on oh
yes there we are that's right we haven't
started yet so you're okay
i can now see you and i can i can also
hear you so i'm assuming all members can
as well
so when you're ready rob will start the
club thank you very much
thank you do i start
yep yep no hopefully you have had an
opportunity to read the background
information that i circulated via email
to all members of the committee on
friday last week
this thing tell the positive economic
and social benefits of this project and
included the educational benefits for
our future generations
so dealing first with the heritage
issues the council's heritage officer
considers that the proposal would cause
a level of harm to a
designated heritage asset ranging
between a very low level
to a maximum of low to medium level
of less than substantial harm the mppf
states that where a development proposal
would lead to less than substantial harm
to the significance of a designated
heritage asset
this harm should be weighed against the
public benefits of the
proposal when consulted at the
pre-application stage the planning
officer wrote
there are no listed buildings that would
be directly impacted by the proposal
however there is a grade one listed
church located to the northwest of the
site
the proposed design of a single store
story barn stroke agricultural building
would not compete with the architecture
of the church and would not detract from
its setting
turning now to the issue of trees these
are fundamental to the ethos of our
children's education
and we have no wish to harm the trees
and we would never
put our children in harm's way the
council tree officer has agreed quite
fairly
that the users of this site would be
more at risk driving to the nursery each
day than they would be
from these trees we intend to fence off
the trees in such a manner that the
children would not be able to access the
area around the canopies and our staff
would be made fully aware
of the potential risks in this request
when consulted
at the pre-application stage the officer
wrote the proposed building would be
single story and designed in a barn
stroke agricultural building style
this design would be acceptable for the
area as it would not appear
out of character or dominating in this
location
and then advised that there should be
plenty of screening around the site to
maintain the rural nature of the area
the submitted scheme takes this advice
on board especially as we want to
include trees for educational as well as
aesthetic
reasons finally you will have seen my
agent's response on the drainage issue
as i have stated in my email to you all
on the other side of the scales a
refusal of this application
will result in the loss to the local
community of a nursery school rated
twice outstanding by ofsted
the loss of 14 jobs and the potential of
five more jobs and two apprenticeships
and a detrimental impact on the working
parents who rely on the nursery to care
for their children
and all at a time when education and
employment are under considerable strain
as a result of the coveted pandemic i
can
do no better than to end with a
quotation from your council's very own
economic strategy
the council realizes that difficult
decisions and fine balances
are necessary and risks must be taken to
secure future economic success
thank you for your time this morning
thank you
uh for that um hands have gone up so
there's
a few speakers that want to put
questions to you for clarification
um counselor barrett your first
sorry about that um good morning um
mrs page um i wondered if you
could i think you there was mention that
you had pre-app
advice from baber could you
just tell us about that and what they
advised
yes we put in a pre-application which
came back very favorably favorably
which is why we went ahead with the
actual planning application we would
never have spent the money that we have
spent to get this
application to where it is now had the
pre-app come back
not in our favor but
specifically on that site was that
identified at that time that you
yes and highways were in favor of it as
well that was one of the biggest things
that we were concerned about that
highways would be
worried or concerned about the location
for the families
but they passed or passed i don't know
what the wording is but they were
quite happy with the site and and how do
you look to any other sites as well
no because there weren't any
spent 18 months searching and there was
absolutely nowhere suitable for our
nursery to relocate
we looked um i joined rightmove i phoned
all the estate agents i
spoke to claire free economic
development um
we were shown some other potential sites
but
when we looked with our architect um the
highways wasn't
ever going to pass it because of ben's
in the road also we had to move on
till eventually this one from mr mr and
brooks mr mrs brooks came up
and it seemed the right location for us
it's got electric there it has bt
there it has water there and a fire
hydrant just over the road
so it seemed quite the perfect place for
us
okay and can you describe the
geographical spread that your
clients come from uh
yes we actually have um families from
billaricki
because their business is in sudbury
they travel to us um mr late
himself lives in colchester um but other
than that it's
mainly sudbury boxford
assington great cornard little cornard
viewers along melford
cavendish blemsford uh levin heath
mayland um
it's quite quite a big they do travel to
us because of what we offer
okay thank you very much thank you thank
you thank you
uh kenzler ayers oh yes
thank you chair good morning donna a
couple of questions for you
um do you have a long waiting list
that's quite a hard question to answer
because we have um
families that are waiting for more
sessions because when you're in
early years or a nursery it's not like
school where you come
monday to friday nine to three some
children come
five mornings a week other children come
five days full time a week because
they've got working parents
other parents work part-time so perhaps
they would come
on a monday and a tuesday until one
o'clock and then they come on a
wednesday afternoon so
when we say a waiting list it depends
what sessions or days that the parents
want dependent on the spaces that we
have available
if that makes sense yes yes thank you
and the second question is
um do you ever have you ever offered
work experience for high school
um students every year thank you
thank you very much for that counselor
ayers uh councillor mclaren
thank you chair uh donna um
i asked a question earlier and it was
referred to you
so um how many sort of
how many each day how many children are
actually attending
the nursery because i mean obviously
it's a wide range age range isn't there
so there'll be babies as well so we
currently have two rooms our baby room
is one to two year olds and when they
turn two they go up into the
nursery room two to five in the baby
room we can have a maximum
of six and we do have a waiting list for
the baby room we take
age of one when mom's maternity leave
finishes and they go back to work
uh in the nursery room the two to fives
we can have
30 a day um but
that's morning and afternoon so we could
have different children in the morning
what we have in the afternoon children
go home at lunch time and then the
afternoon children join or we have
children staying all day
so at maximum of 30 and we do have a
waiting list
on most days for either the morning or
the afternoon
i was i looked at the car parking spaces
that you had and i was just
trying to work out how well used or
people coming and going all the time
presumably so we have uh first drop-off
is eight o'clock in the morning for our
breakfast club for the working families
then the next drop-off is at 9 15 so
perhaps after they've dropped their
school children off and bringing their
younger siblings to us for 9 15 start
then some children will go home at 12 15
or 1 o'clock depending if they stay for
lunch club and then other children might
turn up at one
and go home at four o'clock okay
last question i've got for you um at
this stage of your application
have you included ofsted in in any
discussions
do you is it are you registered with
ofsted or
yes you have to be registered with
ofsted to provide
uh child care we're twice outstanding
provision
and are they are they aware that you are
moving your premises
not at the moment no because i don't
think we'll tell them yet okay
thank you very much thank you thank you
chair
thank you uh councillor jemison
hello good morning um if you're
this application gets approval this
morning
obviously it's going to take some time
before the new
site is prepared and built and ready so
how long have you got
left in your current location how long
before you have to get out and um
we are a year over our eviction date
but our landlord has very kindly and
understandably because then covered hit
and being patient with us so we're
actually on a rolling month-to-month
lease contract with him at the moment um
he wants us out i understand that but at
the same time he's
being patient with us and just allowing
us to stay month on month at the moment
how do you
any any ideas at all how long it would
take before you would be
able to move in into the loop my way
would be in
january but that's not realistic so
i would say if we were to get approval
um with the builder that we've already
currently been talking to and working
with
on the um on the ideas i would hope that
we would be in september next year if we
were able to
get it up that quickly okay great thanks
thank you uh any other
questions of clarification i can't say
any more hands up
no thank you very much then we'll move
on
uh members we now have the county
councillor
uh councillor james finch you sir also
have three minutes in which to address
the committee and i'll service any
questions at the end of it
uh perhaps donna you can turn your
camera off and could
counselor james finch turn his camera on
and mike
please
good morning mr chairman and good
morning councillors
um suffolk county council oversees the
provision of early years learning in the
whole of suffolk
i'm therefore here to only comment on
the importance of early years provision
in the area
i'll start by referring to a joint study
from the universities of london oxford
and nottingham
called the effective provision of
preschool education
eppe this study demonstrated the
positive effects of
high quality preschool provision on
children's intellectual
and social behavioral development three
of the many findings of the study were
attending a preschool compared to none
enhances all around development
duration of attendance and an earlier
start
under three years is related to better
intellectual
development disadvantaged children
benefit
significantly from good quality
preschool experiences
especially when they are with a mixture
of children from different social
backgrounds
why do i say this i was surprised to
read in the report there was not a
perceived need
in the ashington ward here are the
up-to-date statistics for my offices in
the county council for the assington
area
one there are only two years early years
providers
today one full time which is yuliban
36 places for 41 hours a week the only
full-time provision
offering working parents the 30 hours
government
funding scheme and then the other one is
a part-time 18 provision 18 hours
provision in levin heath
only three days a week quality of
provision
yuliban is a proven provider with 12
years of operation
as we've heard it's an outstanding it
has an outstanding
ofsted rating following two inspections
and the school setting has provided high
quality early education and child care
so it's education
and child care in this area for 12 years
as we've heard the nursery school
alongside the county council
and the baby economic development
partner have been trying to find a site
for 18 months
we've been told by the applicant the
nursery school could close
if this application is not successful
may i remind you the child care act of
2006
section 6 places a duty on english local
authorities
to secure sufficient child care for
working parents
section 6 of the act defines sufficient
child care as sufficient
to meet the requirements of parents in
the area who require child care in order
to enable them to take up or remain in
work
in the can in this area rather the
county councils told me there's a
deficit of 32
places in this area with a forecast of
10 needed for next year
if your liban is not allowed to continue
there therefore would be potentially
a deficit of over 70 places in the
immediate area
the new facility will remain still the
only
suitable facility for working parents in
the area at this time
mr chairman can i conclude does the
public benefit of this application
outweigh any harm thank you identified
heritage assets your time is now up
thank you
members is there any questions that you
wish to put to cancer
cancer finch for clarification
any hands no
thank you very much uh yeah counselor
airs we've got a question for councillor
finch
yes and thank you councillor finch i'm
i'm intrigued about the fact that
um matthew late said his child had quite
severe um disabilities
um how important do you think it is for
the integration of the special needs
children
with the other children in this sort of
um development obviously they had a very
good op
offstead but um how do you feel about
that
well uh thank you councillor as can i
just say
the study i referred to at the beginning
of my presentation
said very clearly disadvantaged children
benefit significantly from good quality
preschool experiences
and especially so when they are with a
mixture of children from different
social backgrounds thank you
any other questions anybody no
thank you very much uh yes councillor
busby's just got his hand up
sorry james yeah uh look one of the
things i'm concerned about in this
particular area
is the the number of accidents on the
a134 it's
a particularly bad section of that road
highways have okayed it but would
highways
respond favorably to perhaps a donation
from the applicant to improve the
safety of that road by perhaps lowering
the speed limits or something
um mr chairman councillor busby can i
make two comments
first of all um if the road is unsafe
it doesn't require donations to actually
make it safe
we have a priority of making the road
safe
this particular junction and the
highways officer has
has inspected this and in the context of
the
the highways regulations they adhere to
and in the context of the conditions
they will put on the developer
developing that
site and access they have actually
have no objection am i right canceler
finch i'm thinking that that
a134 the main road before you turn off
to come into the ashington
is a 40 mile limit now yep i mean that
was
i actually got involved in that yes i
know
and that particular junction has been
closed
from an unrestricted to a 40 mile an
hour limit
over the last 18 months i think two
years yeah
okay so it could have had an impact on
the number of accidents great thank you
thank you councillor buzzfeed councillor
hinton
thank you mr chairman councillor finch
just a quick point you pointed there
about you made a point there about the
the importance of early years uh
activity etc
how does that equate with the country
council's uh policy at the moment which
seems to be to close down the children's
centers
well um i don't think that's the fair
question
councillor hinton uh i can actually
answer you
if you wish to answer please do i think
um i think you have to differentiate
between
closing down buildings and closing for
provision
the county council is not closing and
stopping provision
it is actually closing some buildings
and facilitating that and actually
putting
the money that's saved by closing the
buildings will put into more provision
specifically to those in need in the
specific areas throughout the county
thank you any other questions
no there's no hands up thank
thank you councillor finch we'll now
move on to
the local ward member which is
councillor lee parker
you sir have five minutes in which to
address the committee
thank you super job chair thank you very
much
um so um members as ward member i hope
i can give colleagues uh a good insight
as anybody into the specific pressures
that surround this application
and i hope i can do so with balance and
fairness to all parties
it occurs to me there are four areas of
concern at play those being heritage
location an emerging neighborhood plan
and economic considerations
our officers report explains adequately
the reasons for her recommendation and
it will be for members to undertake the
balancing exercise in interpreting any
public benefit that might exist
it is however interesting to see the
differing conclusions reached by our own
heritage officers and the heritage
report submitted on behalf of the
applicant
it's a conundrum that this committee
faces regularly same circumstances but
different interpretation of public
benefit
the agricultural report however does
raise some issues around tpos that don't
appear to be
adequately addressed however whilst the
technical reasons for the recommendation
are adequately described i believe there
are significant other matters at play
that members will need to consider
in their deliberations on the one hand
an established business already already
located in the ward now seeking an
approval
that it states is paramount to its very
survival
on the other a community that has
strived and worked tirelessly over the
last two years constructing a
neighborhood plan that gives a steer
clear
as to the future development of the
parish a plan which is at odds with the
proposal before us
as a passionate advocate of the
neighbourhood planning process i'm
delighted that all four parish
parishes within my ward are well on the
way to establishing their own plans
assington are the furthest ahead in that
process and their plan is currently
undergoing independent examination
the parish council are under no
illusions as to the limited weight that
can be afforded to an emerging plan
but similarly it can't be dismissed with
no weight
this committee is increasingly relying
on those plans that have been formally
adopted
to inform the decisions that we come to
although ashington's plan can only be
afforded very limited weight i do ask
members to give due consideration to the
content of it
assington parish council are not opposed
to yorliban locating within the village
and indeed they have been
at pains to say that if an alternative
site could be located they would seek to
actively accommodate it
to accommodate the school it's just that
this application site is contrary to a
number of imminent plan policies
it carries limited weight but the
policies contained within it
are ostensibly the policies that will
likely be adopted
so mr chairman i ask or we ask our
communities to engage
in the neighborhood planning process are
we to allow that process to fail for
assington at the first hurdle
but what if the applicant themselves
yorliban is a well-established and
well-respected nursery school founded
nearly 12 years ago
it's situated at little corner of the
neighbouring village to asking
it employs 14 people and is rated
outstanding by ofsted
in 2019 the landlord of the premises
that yoliban currently occupied gave
notice to vacate
since then the owners have sought
alternative premises to either rent or
to purchase for themselves
my understanding is that after a number
of false starts at the location
mrs page came to a provisional agreement
with the land owners of the site that is
now being proposed
pre-application advice was sought and
the application we have before us
was submitted assington parish council
have objected to the proposal for the
reason stated previously and the common
thread amongst residents seems to be
that the precise sighting
at this particular location is less than
desirable
but herein lies the nub of the problem
whilst objectors claim the scheme
may well be supported at an alternative
location no alternative location has
been found
that's not to say it doesn't exist but
it hasn't been found
yorliban has invested a substantial sum
of money pursuing this site as one
they have no alternative and two the
imminent threat of closure of the school
as a commercial venture is real
the current landlord at little corner is
also a constituent he's granted a stay
of execution during the covert crisis
and indeed should members be minded to
support this application
will allow time for the school to
complete the development but he does now
require the return of his premises
so i can be absolutely clear to members
chair he has informed me
that should members be minded to support
our officer's recommendation for refusal
he will be insisting on the return of
the current building
it's almost certain under those
circumstances that the school
will have to close with the loss of both
employment and school places
as a committee member i therefore
contend unlike our officer
that there is a significant public and
economic benefit to be weighed against
the reasons given for refusal
mr chairman as ever i trust this
committee to undertake a hearty debate
and to come to its decision whatever
that might be
with all of the facts taken into
consideration and i'll be glad to take
any questions
thank you okay
thank you counselor parker members
have you any questions for kenzala
parker uh councillor busby your hands up
first
lee hi good morning are you aware of any
sites
in your area that could potentially be
used as an alternative
um i i'm i'm not aware of any science
cancer but we know
um and and indeed as part of the
representation that the economic
development team made they they in turn
contacted me
in march of this year to to ask if i
were
aware of any sites and made tentative
representations but
but to answer your question directly i
am not aware of any alternative sites
that are immediately available
no okay thank you thank you
any any other question uh counselor airs
thank you chair um good morning lee
um i was just i'm a bit confused because
they had pre
um planning application and they had
lots of positive things
and then it all changed and do we have
any explanation about that
um i'm not sure whether that's um cancel
at least a
place to answer that but you know what
to have a go and i'll see if i can get
the answer for you a bit later coach
slayers
sure i mean i think in in absolute
fairness council perez i think we all
know that the
the the pre-application advice service
doesn't uh
it doesn't give a determination either
way at the time it's non-committal
um as far as pre-application advice is
concerned but i understand that that can
be
very confusing for for applicants
because the pre-application advice
report is on the website it is available
for members to look at
uh and um and and i would i would say
having read the pre-application uh
report that it's
certainly um it certainly doesn't appear
to be detrimental
thank you uh i think uh council airs
i'll get you to put that question to the
officers when we go into debate
because i think that's the point that we
need clarified
um any other questions to councillor
parker
councillor barrett
good morning um early um
just wondered if you could shed any you
know any insight into
how important this nursery provision is
for um people in in this ward and
and wider do you have any
you know um anecdotal uh
uh sort of recommendations from families
who who use this provision uh
thank you council para and and and
anecdotally only
sorry council barrett sorry yes um um
thank you for the question
um yes anecdotally of course um i hope
you can still hear me i'm getting a sign
saying i've got bad
network quality but um anecdotally of
course yes um
plenty of of of evidence of uh of the
benefit of your lebron the only partner
situated in little cornered
little corner forms part of my ward so
um it it it's a staple part a
significant employer of
of my ward um and certainly as far as
the uh the wider context is is concerned
the school is it's well used and that
that is well documented and of course it
is
uh also well used um by people uh
more locally as well and and within the
village of washington particularly um
so yeah it it's a it's a significant
um contributor um
locally to education uh and to to all
things good
cancer parent thank you thank you
thank you any other questions i can't
see
any more hands going up
so i'll take that as uh
okay no one else put the hands up thank
you councillor parker
we will now move on into debate
uh members it's now up for discussion
and counsellor
airs i'll come to you to put that
question about the pre-application
advice
uh to the officers counselor airs
thank you chair yes i i just found that
it's so strange
could you explain um was it a different
officer could you please
explain what happened there thank you
yeah i think what you're trying to say
is that whilst pre-application advice
doesn't come down
on one side or the other i'm assuming
i would assume that if if the um
plan an officer felt this was definitely
out of order or not likely to be
supported they would have made that
very clear in in the early days is that
what you're saying
yes absolutely thank you right uh i
don't know
mark whether yes you want to come in on
this one i think yeah
i'll answer that i mean there are no two
ways about it that the pre-app
lightly touched the issue of heritage
and then didn't go far enough
to be quite blunt with you um it's
reached the view and actually on a map
you could sort of understand why
somebody might reach the view that
there's a certain distance from the
church therefore
probably not an issue but um actually it
is an issue
and our esteemed heritage colleagues
whether a consultant said actually look
at this view
of the church from glebe house that's
important
so the pre-application had that piece of
information missing from our end
i think we should have gone deeper at
that point and that's probably where
we've got the conflict now
um but we are not tied to
pre-application advice
apart from the fact it doesn't look good
if we if we seem to
bring something new up later on we as an
authority are not tied to that advice
so i just wanted to make that clear
chair
thank you thank you chairman i'm sorry
very sorry to
button on councillor airs but may i just
briefly add
as a matter of law i think this is well
understood by
people in the development industry and
pre-application advice is understood
always understood to be
without prejudice and subject to
consultation those two points are always
made aren't they mark
mr russell i believe to and anyone who
asked for it
i mean i do know i mean sometimes when
we
receive a pre-application request we we
might
decide we really ought to consult
highways at the county because
access or or maybe such a fundamental
issue but in this case
the the planning officer themselves
assess the heritage as best they could
is that right at the time yeah a
fleeting assessment of the fact that
church was nearby
um and in this case i think we have to
say didn't it didn't go far enough
without exploration of that issue
and i think you know on another day one
would have actually
um encouraged heritage input and asked
the applicant to pay heritage advice as
well but it didn't happen
so that's how we've got to where we are
now chair all right thank you
right we're in debate any other comments
uh councillor barrett
yes well just just on that um
issue uh the pre-planning
what was it actually flagged that it was
outside the the settlement boundary
aside from the heritage aspects
what was that and should that have been
um examined in a lot more detail
regardless of heritage surely the
um the settlement boundary is a major
factor and an obvious to anyone
um who uh is is advising on
pre-planning that was known at
pre-application and i think that was
probably flagged up to be honest just
might have in front of her i mean that
wasn't the issue that being outside the
settlement limit was wasn't the thing
that swung it one way or the other um it
was mentioned in commentary but i think
to be
totally sure on that ask jasmine if
she's got the document to confirm that
but
again we're talking about what was wrong
with the pre-app or what wasn't wrong
with pre-app rather than the merits
the planning merits of the case at the
moment which is what we should
concentrate on
well i i take your point but i do think
pre-application advice
when people go and seek advice and i
believe they pay for it now
um that should be uh the best and
and i certainly think a case that i uh
this
uh where there is heritage issues
um that should have been flagged up very
early on i would have thought but
i don't think we're here to discuss that
part now but uh
i i do take the point i do agree with
councillor barrett and ayers on this
um any other comments
any other hands going up
uh councillor busby yeah as usual this
is
this is one of the many cases that we
get which is trying to balance the harm
to
heritage against the benefits to the
broader economy and uh
the public at large and
i guess i take a more pragmatic view on
this i mean on one side
the view is from one building
which is that's quite a way away it is
quite
a pleasant view from that building
through the trees to the church and
there was obviously a link between the
two because
it was i think it's a rectory i think
the glee house or used to be
so there obviously is a connection with
the church but
the loss of that view would affect one
house
people would still be able to see the
view of the church from that turning
into ashington
on the other side of the equation the
loss
of this business would affect
significantly more than
one house or one family and therefore
you kind of think that
on balance we ought to be going in favor
of the
the applicant and
it one of the things that it says in
terms of sustainability
is the development must be sensitive and
responsive to its surroundings and i
think they've made a very good job of
trying to do that
it is a single story building after all
which will be largely but
hidden behind trees and
it's going to be uh using natural
products and that wood etc
so i think they've done everything they
can to make the building
fit the surroundings one of the things
that makes me smile is on page 27 we
talk about
the potential loss of great to
agricultural land
where we talk about losing 0.7 hectares
really is that a really significant
point to consider bearing in mind that
we've got two solar
panel farms applications coming forward
with
dozens and dozens of eight hectares lost
for that
so i i think it on balance
i'm veering towards the applicant rather
than the protection of the heritage
thank you councillor busby um i've
got i believe it's thomas pina
uh the heritage officer uh i think it's
your hand that's gone up is that correct
uh yes it is yeah um i think you'd like
to comment on
on what you've heard from kenzler busby
and president
yep have you put your camera on please
yes good morning yes now oh i recognize
you yeah
chair sorry i think jasmine might want
to put some slides up to look at again
while thomas is talking here is that
okay
uh well let's see what thomas has to say
first okay yes i don't want to address
that
that confuses the um echoes the comments
yep yeah i just want to address the
point on the view and
in terms of what view the view it is
that i think is harmed
is not just a a static view from the
vicarage the glebe house but is the the
view you experience as you travel along
the a1 and 34 heading north um
and from the the side road to the east
as well uh so it is a it's a public view
that
anyone traveling along that road can
experience
and while i think there is also harm to
the to the relationship
um between glebe house and the church
in terms of the the view itself and how
that's harmed it's it is a
a public view it's not just a case of
just the owner of the cleb house
experiencing that view
thank you councillor busby you wanted to
come back on that yeah thanks
i understand what you're saying thomas
is that the only if you're driving along
the a134
is that the only view of the church that
you get that one particular slot through
the trees or
can you see it as you drive further
along um i mean
it's as you drive further along towards
sudbury
yeah yes i mean um you get various
points in which you can
um see the church as you travel along
that route
um you don't i mean in terms of other
directions um it's less visible
approaching from the north approaching
from the suburb direction or approaching
from massington
um but it is more than just a kind of a
very narrow view there is a kind of a
sort of range
as you're moving you you see it for a
little while
okay thank you thank you
uh any other quests any other comments
members
i can't see any hens going up a cancer
barrett
uh you're you're your mic isn't on
what's now you're still off you're still
off
that's it got it now got it now um
as as councillor busby has said uh thank
you for
sort of introducing you know the the the
difficult
uh job we have of weighing up and um
i think it's a good summary actually um
of of some of the the the pertinent
um issues that we have to to deal with
of the the loss of view but
for me that is a very fleeting view of
the church as you drive
i'm i did live nearby um i'm used to
that
that um view emerging to the
left as you drive towards sudbury it is
a fleeting view
and it is mostly in the winter when the
leaves aren't on the trees
um so um i don't
i don't think that outweighs the the
benefit
um of the the nursery um
the issue of quality education is is a
factor here
um is rated outstanding that's not an
easy
um category to attain
through ofsted so um to to achieve that
twice
um uh i think that must be taken into
account
um and the number of places it's not
just an insignificant small
nursery it's quite a offers um
uh wrap around care really for um
parents to um maintain their their jobs
and
um also the sympathetic
buildings um seem to
uh offer a as good a solution as as you
could
you could with a modern building um
i'm sure they would settle in in time
um in terms of the the trees and the
branches and the risk
um i don't know for me wouldn't those
children be
inside if there was high winds anyway um
so i think the risk is very low actually
um although the trees do look you know
they're
a wide spreading canopy um
so i am leaning towards sort of thinking
that the
you know the public benefits um
available
um outweigh the the harm
but i'll be interesting to hear how this
develops and if others want to speak
thank you i do head to others
um i've got councillor osborne followed
by councillor hinton
council i was born yep thank you mr
chairman thank you very much
um yes i thoroughly agree with
councillor baron and councillor busby on
this one
i i too believe that the
loss of staff and the economic benefit
of the nursery
and the well-being of the children and
their parents
that the public advice advantage
outweighs those of the heritage
and i find that an extraordinary comment
to be made by a heritage officer
who is saying that you should be going
along the a134
looking at heritage churches i would
have thought
that actually you're looking away from
the road that you're driving on
and therefore um i can't see any
any significance in in in looking at a
heritage site
off of a main road it's it's it's
it's a real it's a real what's it that
one i i can't understand it
however in defense of him uh in defense
of our officer
i would just say if you drove along the
road in front of stonehenge the traffic
all
slows down and they all lock and it
takes then an extra
15 minutes half an hour to get by it
but uh so people do look but perhaps
they should keep their eyes in front of
them
anyway carry on ken slowest born
absolutely
and i too um cannot
cannot think that the the heritage side
of this
which are which has a council busby has
already stated
is far enough away uh within that uh
build area of the of the nursery if it
comes off
and and all my compliments to the
to um donna and the uh nursery and the
brooks who offered this land i think
that's a real good economic opportunity
for
all the parents that and particularly
those with
with children that need that have needs
um
it's it's a no it's a no-brainer for me
i'm afraid the
the whole thing uh uh the public
advantage outweighs the
harm caused by this and and and i will
be supporting uh
um the applicant's uh uh
agreement on on on having this uh
application
go forward as as a as an approval
thank you nothing's been proposed yet uh
no no i quite understand that but uh
that's where i understand anyway
thank you uh i got councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um i'll put the
camera on and hope that the broadband
holds up
yes yes we can see you yeah but it might
not last long that's the problem
as long as we can hear you then there is
a there is a
there is a dilemma here this this this
business
and let's let's face it it is a business
obviously does supply a valuable service
to
sections of the community ranging across
quite a wide area
including considerable numbers that
aren't even in suffolk
so it's it's a bit of a difficult one
at the same time this council has just
signed up to
climate change emergencies and
biodiversity
approvals and all the rest of it yet
here we are
proposing to hard landscape part of the
countryside
in a fairly sensitive setting
next to a footpath and let's not let's
not forget it is close to
two-foot paths a permissive one and a
public footpath
uh which obviously provides views of the
church as well not just from the a134
the trees themselves are a biodiversity
and yet in other areas
uh and i know that this is where
councillor busby will jump up and down
they do tend to get ignored and chopped
down um
we're we're in danger of being
completely ambiguous in all our
decisions
we don't seem to have any clear path as
to what it is we actually want to do
this is a difficult one the officers
have made a considerable
amount of um case for the
borderline aspects of it if you like uh
and i think that it would be fairly
dangerous for us to go
against their recommendations on this
particular application
considering all the other effects that
might come along
bearing in mind that it is it is outside
the built-up area boundary it's in the
countryside
there are considerable movements every
day to and from it as
the owner of the business said 30
children
maximum at one time but they change over
all the time through the day so there's
considerable environmental pressure from
that point of view
and we can't say that everybody's going
to be running around in in electric cars
because
that's not always the case so it's a
difficult one but i think the officers
have probably got the balance about
right
thank you councillor hinton councillor
plum
thank you chair you
councillor plum right thank you joe um
i'm i'm likely with our council lily
parker i'm a passionate advocate
of neighborhood plans and i'm
in the situation where this business it
is a business as john
has just emphasized has been offered
by the parish council assistance to find
an alternative site
i i think with with how i feel about
um neighborhood plans i i i do not think
that a business
work should overrule what the community
wants
thank you chair thank you thank you
any other comments members any other
hands up
any other proposals
councillor busby well i think the point
that from
uh lee's very informative uh
five minutes is that if we turn this
down we lose the business
so they won't be looking for an
alternative site
thank you uh
i've any new hands up uh
counselor owen yeah i thought
is sorry do you want my camera on uh yes
that'd be helpful people like to see
who's talking
oh so it's gone off again um
yeah um i i just feel that that with
kobe 19
there's so many empty buildings coming
up
and i think we're going to lose so much
of this view
that it's such a hard one because you
know
like everyone says it's a business and i
i think we shouldn't
we shouldn't go for this and we should
go with the officers recommendations
because of
because of losing losing these lovely
views
thank you any other
uh comments
uh councillor hinton
thank you mr chairman um i agree with
council owen in that respect and to
think that there is no
other suitable premises or site so
close to or closer to sudbury as one of
our main
population centers seems a little bit
disingenuous we don't have to keep
putting
all these premises in the middle of the
countryside let's try and get them
somewhere where all the other facilities
are available as well and if the people
work in sudbury then it's obviously an
advantage to them not to have to commute
a long way out into the countryside
to drop their children off and then come
back again and i'm sure there are
business premises
coming available in sudbury uh
on the fringes of sudbury or in
connection with
the development around the outsides of
sudbury
cancer airs
thank you chair um well i am totally
um what do we care about most the
education
of all these children or a view which i
don't think is absolutely that fantastic
and a few trees i think we need to get
the right perspective here thank you
chair
thank you councillor barrett
yes um i think we need to
i need to propose uh that we go to
a vote um i haven't had
any proposal one way or the other so uh
yeah yeah councillor barrett
you've got the floor well uh mark
russell has just put his hand up so
uh sorry councillor barrett sorry chair
just always just want to mop up at the
end of a debate and it's always trying
to pick the moment and i think probably
before a proposal may be the best time
is that all right
just to clarify well a councillor
barrett was speaking are you happy to
help us right thank you uh officer mark
russell
yep thank you chair i just want to
before a vote
even a proposal um so just one or two
points that were raised the agricultural
land
point by council of busby fairpoint but
that wasn't the reason for refusal so
we can park that one um to reiterate the
neighborhood plan has limited weight
so we do have to consider that in any
decision that we make
um the issue about whether it's needed
or not um
it's a commercial enterprise there's
clearly a need otherwise
uh yorley wouldn't be trying to get
their permission so that that's a given
that there's a need for it
um this is land use we're talking about
town and country planning looks at land
use
um and the fact that he's obviously a
stellar nursery no disputing that
um is is not relevant to the issue of a
land use because this permission does
not tie it just to your le it's just
it would have permission for um being a
day nursery um
and i think i'm correct in saying
although they do cater for special
educational needs
that um it's not tied to that either
explicitly
so there's that um and there's another
heritage point which i'm gonna ask mr
pinner to make in a minute
um but a key point we must remember is
that
our officers conclude that this is in
the round
contrary to our development plan which
is a material consideration and that's
how we arrived at the point of
recommending a refusal
so those points for clarification if i
may just pass to mr pinner for one last
uh statement
mr penner would you like to speak
uh yes that's my chair um i just wanted
to uh just clarify some of the points
that were raised
by councillor barrett and councillor
osborne
i just wanted to clarify first of all
that in where i've identified
um it is not just arising from the view
setting encompasses more aspects than
just views
and how highlight
issues of um undeveloped setting of the
church and
the erect uh vicarage the glebe house
um and also the potential erosion of
tranquil tranquility
um these are all things that they're not
necessarily dependent upon on views
um existing at the at present or even in
the future um
to still be harmful and then just the
point i suppose
to go back to the just the view aspect
of it um i think
i'm already convinced by the the um the
arguments i think was put forward in the
um
heritage response as well that um people
on the a134 would be
focusing on the road because i think you
have to consider um
passengers in any vehicles um
and also i mean there's potential for
for pedestrians to be
to be using that there is a um a post
box on that junction
um so and on also other points i think
it is important um to consider what
views would be like in winter
and also if um vegetation cover is
reduced because
there's no guarantee that it will remain
for the long term i mean it's subject
subject to
natural processes of processes of decay
um so i just wanted to kind of just
clarify those points
um make sure they were obvious thank you
thank you very much yes i think they're
all valid points
but i i think it's fair members have
traveled
up and down that road in winter and
summer and most likely know the
vegetation
that's there or not there at any
particular time councilor barrett i'm
coming back to you now
thank you um
i don't think i don't think that changes
my um original or what i was what was
saying was
that we we should move to a vote and i
i'm going to propose that we
uh approve um
this we've we've we've got some on the
this committee we've got some people are
very passionate
about securing children's um
future and good outcomes from them and
also people who are passionate about
heritage and landscape and and those
other factors
um and it's very difficult um
i do need uh the reasons um
benefits and um some of the comments
you're making
um regarding okay um
i think the benefit outweighs the harm
the benefit of securing
this provision of child care and nursery
education
in this in this location because
although we
can foresee you know moving it
potentially being provided in a sudbury
or elsewhere
um that's not meeting the needs of the
local villages
um and so i think it it needs to be as
close to
its original location as as possible
um and
so i believe that is the fundamental um
issue the the benefit of securing the
the nursery provision to be local right
thank you tell me all right
yeah i was just trying to look at the uh
i'd wrote down so many
um things as we were going through um
but i think you're referring to
um uh page 27 of the national canon
policy
um 94 and 97 i believe was
pointed out to us uh not 97
uh 1998.
um first of all i better see if
there's a seconder do i have a seconder
right there's a councillor busby your
hands gone up
yep yeah i'm happy to second that chair
and uh did you want to help with any uh
other reasons
as to why i think
it's primarily on the balance of harm
versus benefit
one of the phrases that one of the
comments that was in the report is that
whilst it is acknowledged that the
nature of the forest
nursery requires a rural setting it is
considered that as the district is
primarily rural
there are more suitable places for such
a facility
well where if you're looking for a rural
forest nursery it is almost likely
going to be in agricultural type
settings so this seems to be probably as
good as we're going to get
um so i i just think it's an ideal place
for this kind of setting and they're
doing a
the design is is hard it's in harmony
with what's around it
and therefore the benefit of the hole
is greater than the potential harm
thank you i can't put it in numbers no
no
thank you um right so i'd have to
propose in a second that
um any other comments to this counselor
plum
your hand is up
sorry chad just forgot to take it right
okay
um officer mark russell did you want to
comment on what you've just heard from
the proposal and secondary
yes chair um it's just basic if it's
moving towards uh councillor barrett's
recommendation for approval
she's given some ideas about the themes
but um if we could
i'm not being punished but if somebody
would know i realized that
we would have to state because um not
withstanding policy x
it complies with paragraphs so and so
and policy so-and-so
so i don't know i mean for example
paragraph 127 of the mppf
talks about inclusive inclusive
developments that sort of thing
um we need to add a bit of flesh to the
bones if we're going towards uh
recommending an approval all right yeah
one two
seven yep sorry who's that uh policies
you're relating to the economy that we
can bring in we seem to
got a lot of policies here that relate
to residential stuff but
if we looked at the policies that are
encouraging
the economy in our area then couldn't we
use those
okay yeah i think that's quite uh
acceptable
um the the uh i think there was
something in the four
pints that the officers had put forward
was full
fallen trees within the site uh
um and this was to do with branches and
perhaps unsafe trees and what have you
um but i i would have thought that that
could have been picked up
um there was offers made to
fence around there or to keep children
in in high winds
can that be picked up anywhere
uh i'd say uh we've got the legal advice
she wants to come in yes please
i will i think you need more help from
mark and jasmine than me but i i will
i think it is i can help you at this
point by saying
um go back to first principles if if
this was the other way around
if you were if you had a recommendation
to approve and then we
later had some legal challenge a court
will
would assume that you you would follow
the officers
if you were agreeing with your officers
that you followed their reasoning in the
report
unless there was a strong indication
otherwise here you have an officer's
recommendation to refuse
it absolutely is your democratic
prerogative to disagree with that but
the there is no in law there's no
general duty to give reasons for an
approval
but there are occasions where you're
disagreeing with
an officer recommendation it might not
in every case but it might in some cases
arise
that well what i'm saying at the very
least you need to formulate
or be satisfied yourself of why
decisions being made and i
in this case what concerns me um
is that the the officers are advising i
hope i think i have understood this
correctly i've
have having read the report in detail
and listened to
my officer colleagues that the remember
the statutory test
section 386 you must make a decision in
accordance with the development plan
unless material considerations indicate
otherwise and the nppf
which is important in this case is a
material consideration not part of the
actual plan
so you have mark and jasmine advising
you that
this is contrary to the plan the
policies of the development plan read as
a whole
and the material considerations don't um
move you in the other direction so i
think i obviously have heard counselor
barrett and other
members um on what might well be the
majority of the committee
saying that they disagree but i think
you may you will need some more help
from mark in formulating how we
put that into words that will i hope
keep the council legally watertight
and maybe we may need to go back to the
chain of reasoning on the on the
development plan policies
that's all from me at the moment i think
that's very good advice
um and but i am getting the feeling from
members that
they they're feeling that there are more
benefits to the public
in going with this than uh being against
it
and um i i feel that uh
that's where we need perhaps to get mark
to come in to help out on this
particular one
sorry just come in even in the offices
report under the principle of
development
the final conclusion is that the on what
page can you tell page 28
28 we can keep that the location
is sustainable for its end use that's
the office's conclusion
so whatever we say about all the various
policies cs1 cs15 cs11 etc the
conclusion of the officer is that it's
sustainable
84 of the npps stresses the opportunity
to enable
rural services and businesses may result
in development in areas
outside of existing settlement
boundaries which is what this is outside
of the existing settlement boundary of
ashington
but the development must be sensitive
and responsive to its surroundings which
i think it is
so we end up with this
planning balance argument the harm
versus the benefits
i don't know what policy numbers that
relates to but that's
that's as simple as it chair if i may i
think i'm
just sorry um members uh councillor
busby's referring to the national plan
and policy
framework uh page 24 paragraph 84 that
could be used i i agree with ken
supposed to be on that one
um officer mark russell yeah i was going
to suggest if we could understand
the themes um i think i'm going to ask
for an adjournment so we can
work up the wording and we come back to
you so i'm getting at the moment that
the
public benefits um did council about
also suggest it was
basically a local you know employment
basically
so definitely there's employment in a
counsellor busby
sorry cancer barrett
kenzler barrett
you're muted
sorry yeah um that the benefit
i think was when we saw the slide that
jasmine presented i think it was on on
one of her slides to say the
um benefits i think there was a there
was a flaw in that because it was
um uh we were talking 23 i think that is
yeah it's like slowly 23. sorry i think
that's where the benefits were
make a note of that yes jasmine you can
find that for us
you know that's that's something i would
dispute that the
um the assessment of the benefit being
limited
is not it's a major public benefit
because because the free school places
that is funded by the government
so it's available for all regardless of
income
okay so yeah the the yeah the waiting
exercise there is well that's why we're
here
um so councillor barrett's uh proposal
would be along the lines of
it's a local business the economic
benefits and also the public benefits in
having that facility that though
so notwithstanding the identified
heritage harm
those benefits are deemed to outweigh
the harm
so that's that um and that would include
you therefore be including the landscape
as well in that you'd be saying although
there's some
alteration to the landscape um that is
not outweighed by the benefits
and you would suggest a landscaping
condition one presumes
uh what uh if you know if we go for
approval
um but the other thing is the the um
the foul sewage etc so were we to go
with an approval at this stage
it would still have to be pending on
that on that particular
item well the sewerage being uh sorted
out
but that can be a condition that
provided they satisfied them
on that it could be a condition but the
trouble is that that natural english has
phrased it in the way of objection at
the moment pre-pre-decision now we have
to have a discussion with them
um i suppose the mechanism would be this
is looking forward a few stages
we might have to come back if we can't
sort it out but but substantive issues
of of the of the very fact of it being
there and it
having some effect on heritage and the
landscape
members have weighed that up and if they
agree with councillor barrett in that
weighing exercise they're found in favor
of the benefits
outweighing the harm but we need some
policies and
paragraphs to hang that off before we go
any further right
yeah and can you want to do that in the
german
i think there's no point in everybody
sitting there twiddling their thumbs
while we talk about
well you know there's no point so we're
going to separate meeting uh we're not
we're not going to try and undo the
decision
no it's just we're giving you the proper
words to make the decision yeah
well um go on through you're quite right
because um
as councillor busby uh said paragraph 84
uh says a lot of what i think members
are trying to say uh
benefits outweigh the harms members that
were also thinking
so we do need to pick them all up so
shall we take a ten minute
um well a german will come back at um
20 to 12. is that yeah can we make that
quarter two just to give you
yes okay all right chair before we do
that can i just
make a point about the the fact that
it's not in the low neighborhood plan
and in our local plan it's because
these processes take quite a
considerable amount of time
and this has come forward quite recently
therefore there's no reason i mean when
you start a
neighborhood plan or a joint local plan
you don't think of
every possibility you can't think of
every eventuality
and why would you why would we in the
joint local plan start to
try and plan where children center
should be et cetera et cetera
it's it's too detailed for
for a generic local plan and we have the
local plan has to be flexible enough to
to cater for things that come forward at
the last minute like this thank you
i think the officers have got um the
jest of um
of what we're trying to do uh they're
going to go away
and members will all come back at um 11
45 and we'll pick it up from there
please don't discuss this or anything
while
we're in um adjournment okay
so i just asked robert if he could stay
on to help me because i can't get
something up on my other screen
i need a technical point thank you very
much
i'll leave you with uh manny because i'm
going to go and join
mr russell yeah yeah i'm afraid but
mandy or claire will be
mandy and you will stay there so i'll
just say to members
um just turn your mics and cameras off
and then return at um
11 45 okay thank you
welcome back members um right i'll ask
um officer mark
to um russell to
um update us yeah thank you chair
um just so you can see me yes
yes please itself off yeah so we had we
had to talk about
um if members were to agree with
councillor barrett's
recommendation and and it was decided
that the best way of doing it would be
to spell out
um how there is a conflict with a plan
but
so the proposed wording and and council
barry is not tied to this you might want
to change it proposal is
broadly accept the officer's advice that
it's contrary to the development plan
bread as a whole
specifically the policies cs15 cno6
cr040708 which are heritage and
landscapes
i couldn't get them all down so anyway
carry on yeah i've
i've i can well they're in writing here
and i can for them in a minute but so
specifically cs15 i'll say it slowly
sorry that's what you're asking to do
isn't it
cs15 cn06 cr04
cr07 cr08 um
whilst there is that conflict there is
considerable public benefit
in accordance with paragraphs 84 92
and 127 f
which enable us to engage the public
benefit test
as per paragraph 196 of the nppf
six yeah all right i've got that i know
where they are
there's some more i'm afraid in addition
it is recognized that cs15 um clause
i roman numeral one does not enable the
public balancing exercise
therefore and also in reference to
policy cs17
i believe that an assessment of the
planning balance leads me to conclude
that permission should be granted so
that would be councillor barrett's
proposal would have to reword it into
the
this authority but you know that that
would be the the framing of the wording
chair
right councillor barrett um
uh have you um you've heard all that
and uh um are you taking that on board
i'm trying i'm trying to absorb it um
yeah
just having a look at cs15i
if i need to yeah cs15 values i think it
was
just that i won
jasmine do you have to up that that
clause for council just to make it
easier
i think i have yeah i have got it up if
it's easier for me to do please
please do
i've got it actually but um wow right
did you want me to still share my screen
or
uh yes that would be helpful yep okay
keep bear with me
now the issue with that um chair and all
others is it doesn't open up a
possibility of of
weighing up public benefits it just says
you've got to be kind to
old buildings and views so so in that
sense it's not mppf compliant
so that particular paragraph doesn't
allow us the opportunity to balance it's
just it's quite restrictive
so that's been criticized that appeal so
that's why that paragraph has been
flagged up for you
right so are you saying that we don't
want to take
this one into uh account
or you do it's saying that despite the
fact that maybe conflict with the rest
of cs15
that paragraph is not mppf compliant and
we then refer to the mppf which allows
us to take that um
weighing up the benefits um path yes
that's why it's been flagged
up right yep i understand you're happy
with that uh counselor barrett
um i think i think i have to
i have to agree i mean sorry i know
you've been given little notice there
there council but it's
in in effect it's it's it's you're
you're accepting the officer's view that
there is a conflict
with the development plan but your view
is that the material considerations
otherwise
are such that you can that you've
arrived at a point of recommended
approval
yeah yeah yeah benefits yeah
yeah yes that's right that's my my view
yeah okay okay
and the second uh uh councillor busby
are you happy with that
uh yes chair um
i probably would have added in lp what i
don't know whether it's still the right
number lp 29
services and facilities within the
community provision retention
well that's a good one l p
29 29. i also think for the nppf i think
there's more than just paragraph 84 i
think
83. well yes you could use quite a few
of them but i think i was just
condensing it
i think 83 we spoke about that there's a
reason we thought that wasn't relevant
jasmine can you come in and remind us
why that wasn't yeah
bear with me i'm just gonna stop
presenting and get it up
um
it says that planet planning policies
and decisions should enable
the sustainable growth and expansion of
all types of business in rural areas
both through conversion of existing
buildings and well-designed
new buildings that's right yeah actually
mark i think that was
meant to go in there okay 834 okay yeah
yep good 18 29 as well
and power 83. and then also to the the
point i made about the pla
the plans being taking a lot of time 81
d says be planning policies should be
flexible enough
to accommodate needs not anticipated in
the plan
that that's a policy level thing that's
not a development management thing so we
wouldn't put that in for planning
all right okay well i think
we've got uh you've got enough there
councillor barrett
and councillor busby if you're both
happy
so um then uh
is there any other comments people want
to make before i put that
proposal forward
nope right it's been proposed by kenzler
barrett
um and i'm not going to read them all
out again because
you've heard them unless you want me to
i've got all the numbers down
but in case i miss any um it was cr15
c cn06 cr07
cro8 and then paragraphs 92
127 196
cs15 little value cs17
lp29 paragraphs 83 and 84 of national
planning
policy framework
but could i i mean because these are
recorded and people could look at them
any time afterwards
i'm going to just read out the whole
thing just okay that's very good
yes that would be very helpful because
you've got it all in front of you i've
had to write it down yeah
right um first of all just sorry
clarification counselor
lp 29 uh before we proceed any further
yeah that's right that's the answer to
the bus be sure
just close it yeah just so we know we
doing the right thing sorry
and then i'll read it out
uh yeah lp-29 the aim of the policy is
to support and safeguard
key services and facilities within the
districts which play an important role
within the community
in particular within rural communities
where provision is limited in the
interest of maintaining sustainability
and quality of life
okay um what i'll do i will just check
that's a saved policy
have you got confirmation that is a safe
policy because we've lost quite a few
yeah i see i haven't got the latest
version no so okay
i'll tell you that right you want me to
check mark
can you just do that jasmine sorry i
know it's just talk to us but uh sorry
for the applicant having to go through
this but
it's best to be safe up front yeah
uh you're happy with the rest did you
want to carry on with them while we're
waiting for that to be confirmed
i'll say all of it apart from that and
then jasmine will clarify at the end so
um just add in 83
and the wording was thus um from
council about proposal was and we will
slightly tailor the wording to make it
the decision of the authority is
but these would be councillor barrett's
words i broadly accept the officer's
advice this is contrary to the
development plan read as a whole
specifically policies
cs15 cn06 cro4
cro708 but there is considerable public
benefit
in accordance with paragraphs 83 84
92 and 127 f
of the mppf which enable us to engage
the public benefit
test as per paragraph 196
of the mpps in addition it is recognized
that cs15
roman numeral one does not enable the
public balancing exercise
therefore and in reference to policy
cs17 and possibly lb29 we'll find out in
a minute
i believe that an assessment of the
planning balance leads me to conclude
that permission should be granted
jasmine do we have the lpinto 29 um
so in terms of lp that isn't actually
a policy i can't see anywhere and it's
certainly not
it's certainly not a saved policy but if
council busbee wanted to clarify
which document he's looking at
local plan july 2019
it's the emerging plan yes ah okay
no i i wouldn't um no that's got such
limited weight counter i'd advise not
citing that as a policy at the moment
right rotate that one out and cancel
apology so that was the proposal chair
over to you members sorry yep oh okay
uh councillor busby we've taken out lp
29
but the rest all there counselor barrett
you're happy
yes i am yes and your secondary
counsellor busby
yeah right you've all heard members that
has been put
and spout out to us by the planning
officer
all those in favor of approval
please uh indicate in the roll call
uh four against abstain um
robert would you like to take us through
the um roll call
thank you chair so if members could
please respond as led out with four
against or abstain
councillor sue ayers four
councillor melanie barrett four
counselor peter boo four
councillor david busby four
that's the john hinton against
council lee jameson four
councillor mary mclaren four
counselor adrian osborne four
councillor allison owen against
and council stephen plum against
thank you chair um i make that seven
votes to
four or three against mr dupree do you
confirm yes i agree with your accounting
the resolution is passed by seven votes
to three
thank you thank you very much then that
is approved
uh chair we will take we'll take away
the statutory consultant's conditions
then
um and that we have the conversation
with um natural england but
you've given approval but we'll take
away the status of consultants
conditions
thank you very much yep uh
right i think we've now got to the end
uh yep um just to
tell members the the meeting on
wednesday second december 2020
is cancelled the next one will be the
16th of december and at the moment
that's likely to be on
um you're going to mention the yeah
i've just got to close the meeting
officially